we like to talk about video games here
on the lobby what but being a video game
website but hey Mark Waltons here and a
bunch of apple news done happened yes ad
on my friend good could see it how was
London how's London yeah um not as nice
as San Francisco is in the moment has
very sunny here are a it's not where
there's not to go back no it's kind of
great interest in horrible it's London
you're under one you're here in a
special secret mission right now right I
am here on a secret special mission that
I unfortunately can't talk about
entirely but I'm here for a big tech
event that isn't the apple of em okay
and they're gonna be some cool gaming
hardware things some good news to look
out for them this a couple weeks okay
looking forward to it ever right now
there was Apple news and looking at your
your wonderful tablet here I see your
watch what the goddamn hell happened
today so there were loads there was a
lot of announcements in the apple thing
I mean obviously the one that ever was
going to talk about it's not so much a
gaming thing but will quickly go through
it is the Apple watch it's a SmartWatch
everyone loves smartwatches right anyone
I oh I love mine oh there no am I the
only one by wearing an actual watch yes
okay because this really 14 watch is it
cool okay this is a cool stylish yeah
right are these four watches stylish
that's arguable right beauty is in the
eye of the beholder yeah I think they
look quite cool but I think the big
thing is it's square not round right
right everyone's like oh the motorola
one that's r and this is square it does
lots of cool stuff it has fitness stuff
on it it's made of really expensive
stuff is gonna cost like 350 but wait is
that a feature well it's gonna cost 350
bucks I think it was 350 don't quote me
on that my 350 or three now I think
that's like the starting mob it's the
stock model for the stainless steel one
there's now a minium one for sports
fiends or aluminum for Americans yes
that being correct and they would there
is true and failed aluminum it's spelled
the lumina here it is oh yes very good
we just straight-up retcon that's
ridiculous and there's one more made of
18 karat gold really yeah that's the dr
dre model yes so what to do look why
would you want to have this in your
hands well look at the end of the day
right with the SmartWatch stuff a lot of
them that they're sort of work in
progress right there's all lot of stuff
going on with them this one you know
there's a usual fitness stuff there's
like maps on it you can like like take
holes on it you can look at your tweet
so you can look up the facebook stuff
you know it i think the difference with
the apple one compared to the others
it's much better integrated the OS looks
fun and it's got this that the thing
with it is a new interface it's got like
this digital crane basically you know
like on a watch you have like the
tourney thing yeah use that to zoom in
and I ok yeah it's really simple I know
it sounds really all it is yeah yeah no
no one L no one else has done that right
so I mean it's yeah it sounds like a
cool interface like the one where you
can basically like connect to someone
else's you can send them the little
doodles that you just i believe all
around look at this nonsense and you can
also horn is watchful is so slow motion
hot one magnets a certain nuts yeah yeah
you can you can send doodles you can
send like your own heartbeat so you can
feel someone's heart beat someone else's
heartbeat coming through its got like
this like a message of life finally no I
don't work how long will be waiting for
this now it's got like a haptic like
motor thing in its ok instead of like
vibrating itself supposed to feel like
it just taps you gently ok yeah can i
play like Angry Birds by like like
flicking my wrist up like every couple
of seconds or so I guards flappy bird
flappy bird yeah no you can't do that we
can can play games on the new iphone 6
or iPhone 6 plus a new phone yes great
like current phone is even more old male
yes every day Danny ya know so iphone 6
iphone 6 plus 4 I guess forget Wow yeah
you need a new phone need to fix that
bad you're gonna need a lot of money to
buy an iphone 6 or iPhone 6 plus like if
you get one unlocked it's well it's a
lot really yeah it's a lot of money I
think I believe it it goes well up to
like nine hundred and something dollars
like you if you want it unlocked without
a contract for the 128 gig model okay
for the iphone 6 plus so i guess the big
thing with this for games is that it's
got a new a8 processor okay it's got
this new API which they announced a
while ago but is designed to work with
the new a a processor which basically
means low level access to the hardware
you get really nice fancy graphics and
they wheeled out is affinity blade 3 it
wasn't infinite it wasn't infinity blade
3 it was super evil mega cool although I
wouldn't have been surprised if it was a
infinity blade 3 knows a game called out
vainglory which I was saying a 60 frames
per second
a little bit of a dig towards the next
gen consoles where there was you know
they were saying like this runs at a
higher resolution than a next-gen
console my god and it's a phone you know
so the play destiny that doesn't play
destiny you get the Destiny app on it
why do we even have it on this week's
show if it doesn't play destiny that's
the only stream clearly I'm the only man
in the world that hasn't played s yeah
probably yeah I think we'll probably fix
that later on today yeah Chris you don't
wanna watch is this is this finally
gonna get you out of your watch apathy
no I I don't I've never really want to
watch so having a thing on the wrist is
like a barrier for me I I don't know
what I would use it good looking at what
time it is like okay let me just check
what time it is oh my god Oh yup sure
it's that time I see I like being able
to check on my wrist for the watch okay
it's one of those things you like very
good but what if like somebody calls you
and your phone rings in your pocket and
your friggin wrist wing rings are you
gonna be that guy who's like like like
yes Starfleet scum and Daniel yes hello
don't you want it to be the future no
okay like people who should be now glass
holders are we gonna call these people
wrist holds look okay watch holds I'll
torque on it we all laughed like the
iPad when that was announced to alas no
one's gonna war one of those show big
ipod touch whatever look what happened I
mean admittedly tablet sales I have
stagnated and are going down but okay
for a little while tablets what you're
wrong okay yeah but you could okay say
the same thing about like that's the
argument people used for like the wii u
i bet the wii and also i also like you
could say the same thing about like
google glass yeah you could say that
that's odd much like them look at the
other day I mean for me the watch it
looks cool I'm the only stipulation with
it is that you need an iOS device so you
need an iphone 5 or higher to use it I
actually on you or just usually just
sync it occasionally it means that I
think they need to they work together
okay so that they're sort of repairing
they need to be together which sucks for
me because i switch to android like last
year really but now i'm like i kind of
want the downwash walk in a switch but
have they said what the battery life is
no okay happen simple the batteries on
reason why i haven't said that yes
absolutely absolutely because everyone
was like what's the battery life on this
thing and just like stunts on it's all
so not out until 2015 oh really yeah
right start of the year so you know the
iphones actually out much sooner I
believe it's next week or the week after
so you can go stand in line get yourself
an iphone 6 plus 1080p display BAM its
massive those are really yes okay it's
big it's like Galaxy Note big and get
your pre-orders inferior your Apple not
even fit in a pocket it can fit a human
but there is a smaller one there's a 4.7
inch one you okay much better markets
get this in his pocket this is this is
this is a surface three making me the
second person in the world to oh the
surface three apart from kevin van org
okay um so yeah okay nice work yet
anything else on the upper front well oh
really i mean you look at the end of the
day I'm quite I'm quite excited I've
been meaning to switch back to Apple for
a little while I wanted a bigger screen
phone maybe not as big as that 1080p one
right as you know but it you know a
tenday its usual app of stuff better
cameras it looks sexy everyone's going
to want one it costs a fortune there you
go Apple scheduled three orders in now
what's mark Walton thank you very much
going on no way
you